crises sanitaires et économiques
confinement le moral des français n'a
jamais été aussi bas 13,5 pour cent des
personnes âgées de 15 ans ou plus parle
de symptômes évocateurs d'un état
dépressif un bilan en nette augmentation
comparé à l'année 2019
plusieurs facteurs expliquent ces
pathologies isolement les conditions de
logement
le manque de contacts sociaux et la
dégradation de la situation financière
tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes
capacités pour lutter contre le blues du
coc vide
selon cette même enquête réalisée par la
direction de la recherche des études de
l'évaluation et des statistiques les 15
24 ans seraient les plus touchées plus
10% par rapport à 2010 9 un constat
partagé par l'université de bordeaux
l'établissement a mis en place une
formation dédiée à la détection de ces
troubles
dépression pensées suicidaires les
enseignants qui apprennent à repérer les
premiers signes de détresse
psychologique
opéra du confinement en fait à a poussé
beaucoup d'entre nous à gérer des
situations que pour les quarts n'étaient
pas vraiment préparé donc en des
étudiants venaient vers nous on serait
sûr de détresse sont
nous disaient ouvertement vous avez des
pensées suicidaires beaucoup d'entre
nous ne savait pas comment le gérer on
essaie quand même de leur assurer on
n'est pas des flics on n'est pas des
professeurs et de santé on aide les
étudiants comme eux et peut-être que
nous aussi on vit quelque chose comme ça
ils ne savent pas donc c'est à partir de
là quand qu'on arrive à apprend la
autres catégories à risque les femmes là
encore l'adresse observe une
augmentation + 3,3 pour cent
une des causes avancées par l'étude le
fait de se retrouver face à des
comportements violents agressifs et
dégradant de la part du conjoint ou du
partenaire pendant le confinement les
violences familiales ont grimpé près
d'une femme sur dix a porté plainte pour
violences en 2020 30% d'entre elles
l'ont fait pour la toute première fois
l'étude liste aussi 4 source de troubles
mentaux quatre problèmes qui dans ce
contexte de pandémie ont pris de
l'ampleur
le fait d'être confiné seul ou dans des
foyers surpeuplée aurait favorisé des
états dépressifs par exemple sur ces
questions de santé mentale
les médecins sont en première ligne
trois sur quatre affirment que les
consultations pour stress troubles
anxieux ou dépressifs sont plus élevés
qu'avant la pandémie pour 16% d'entre
ces pathologies aurait même doublé en un
an
des chiffres qui explique sans doute la
nouvelle stratégie du gouvernement
confiné sans enfermer